SKH durchführen
01, hier 10. Melde: eigener Standpunkt Deckerhaus.
Benötige Med-Evac
Ein schwer Verwundeter. Mögliche Landefläche:
Freie Fläche Alpha, 500m vor eigener Position
Kommen:
Kiowa 62 Formation. Wind 2 at 0 degrees
5 knots, runway 26 cleared for take-off
Wir fliegen die Mission wie gebrieft! Tiefsstflug bis Deckerhof. Du machst das, los geht´s!
Aufgaben des Supervisors?
Hier haben wir das Hydraulik-Deck...
...und da unten ist das Flight-Management-System
Black 72, ich gehe in den Tiefflug über.
Bleib dran!
Black 72, bleib dran!
Achtung, Fliegerabwehr vor uns.
Tief bleiben und am rechten Rand fliegen
Black 72, übernimm die Führung!
Wir steigen und klären auf.
Achtung, Leitung ca. 200m vor uns.
Rechts, heading 240
Tief bleiben.
Noch tiefer, unter die Bäume
Fliegerabwehr bei Staudamm.
bleib tief.
Auf mein Kommando hochziehen
Warten noch.
Jetzt hoch!
Links ab.
Rauchkörper, eigene Infantrie.
Du landest an, wir sichern
Gruppe hat aufgesessen, return to base.
Wir übernehmen die Führung, melde wenn aufgeschlossen!
Tulln Tower, this is the Kiowa 62 formation.
Requesting entering clearance and
we have one wounded person on board.
Kiowa 62 formation, enter control zone via Stockerau.
I will inform the med evac team
Super Mission! Echt gut gemacht.
Wir sehen uns beim de-briefing